oh my gosh i'm about to go on my first
date
hannah brown is back in the dating game
god bless america
the former bachelorette hit up her
youtube channel on wednesday to reveal
that she started dating again
and she's doing it just like everyone
else online
i haven't been on a date since the show
so this
is a big deal right now the 26 year old
revealed that she signed up for a dating
app
and matched with four guys she's
planning on going on dates with
i'm just putting myself out there i'm
like you know what this is the time
to have some good old mask fun
there's no pressure for anything because
of
the world that we live in right now i
mean i'm not gonna just like
freaking start macking on you i don't
know you so it just kind of like gives
that good
boundary i think that i'm in full
support of right now in my life
hannah's first date was a double date
with a friend and the group
played paddle tennis we will discuss it
later
mid date she gave fans an update and
said she wasn't feeling it
okay um crazy turn of events i
ditched my last date and now i'm going
on another one
she went out with another guy
skateboarding but there
still wasn't that spark he's still an
attractive
guy really smart as soon as i walked up
to him i know
like it's not there and i definitely
think that spark can grow sometimes but
there has to be
at least a little spark the other hurdle
hannah's dealing with in her
post-bachelorette dating life
is people knowing her story before she
has the chance to tell it
since it's out there and you know i did
say there's something that peter and i
did
twice it was actually
four times as for date number three well
he wasn't her future hubby either three
strikes i'm out
but i have another at-bat next inning
but hey at least the food was good it
was so good
i had the chilean sea bass it was
great of course all this comes after the
dramatic
ending of her season of the bachelorette
last year
that's a lot to unpack but um she got
engaged to jed wyatt during the finale
hannah yes
[Music]
will you marry me then hannah ended her
engagement weeks later when she found
out he had a girlfriend
back home the reason i held back details
that i did
was because i was scared that if i told
you you'd walk away from me
that's when the reality star asked out
her runner-up tyler cameron
but things quickly fizzled out everybody
thought we were in love
hannah and tyler reunited earlier this
year and even quarantined for weeks
together in florida
though they claim they never even kissed
people think they were hooking up the
whole time
18 days in the same bed never kissed
never kiss
well you kept farting they didn't end
their time together on the best terms
by that point like i was just so i don't
think i was very nice that day you were
definitely not nice that day
but they hashed it out on her youtube
channel last month
we care about each other there for each
other and like
i think it's like i'm super stoked to
work her out right now
you